what's up reject nation we're going to
catch up on some game trailers just two
for now first one will be pragmata
second will be resident evil
village and if you just want to skip the
pragmatic one here's the time stamp for
the resident evil one before
we go into this though i'd like to issue
a sincere apology
on behalf of john and i when we did our
ps5
hardware reveal trailer reaction there
was about
10 to 15 seconds in the commentary we
said
well let me just play it for you let's
add a little bit more detail into like
the insides of the mechanics effect yeah
how much memory is in this thing how
powerful is the processor what kind of
outlets are we looking at
i mean i'm sure that information is
there somewhere online probably you can
just read a break
little did we realize that apparently
the specs were
already unveiled leading up to this
event
months ago they've been out and somehow
we missed this information
i get why people were so mad at us
probably didn't help too i said that the
playstation
kind of looks like a version of an xbox
you can't cross those two over it's like
dc marvel
it's just with everything going on in
the world especially in the year
2020 this was the thing
i should have been most informed about
and should have been most sensitive to
we really let you guys down some people
might think i'm being sarcastic in this
apology
i'm not at all oni
it's important whoopsie
i would like to thank whoever posted the
information in the comments though
[Music]
okay
147 things you missed in the opening
shot
i look like a giant cassette dude
[Music]
that looks like one of my cats
she's real i guess
robocat whoa
oh cool
damn
whoa
[Music]
nice wow
oh
wow
what is that
whoa dude
the death stranding universe continued
he's about to say he's gonna take his
helmet off and be norman reedus yeah it
kind of looks like a
luxurious a lot of different games i'm
more of a futuristic bioshock in some
ways too but a lot of sister
a lot of death stranding as well that's
neat so something on
earth i mean it's a brand new game and
not much is known about it right not to
my knowledge i read
john red this time it's capcom game
almost hideo kojima like game yeah is he
involved in it i don't think he is
something's happened to earth and what
he's looking at are like past remnants
that are capturing whatever event
took place right that's what i'm
assuming yeah he finds his life form
this little girl was it one of those
stories again where
man adult finds special little girl
she's like
actually really a badass cool little
girl that he you know is probably
protecting and saving throughout the
game for a while but really she's super
freaking important to that i mean i love
that action hero trope i really do
sound like i'm making fun of it it's
like one of my favorite action hero
tropes for some reason
leon learns a lot from little matilda
logan and laura logan laura
or joel and ellie yeah yeah yeah that's
a very common trophy
i'm your favorite grown man young
girl duo the graphics look really cool
and i like this good mysterious build
now this doesn't come out till 2022 so
now we just got to keep people's
interest for uh
a couple years now yeah we got to react
to next year's trailer i mean that's the
fun thing about video games is that they
can release a trailer years in advance
and people will be just heavily
anticipating it
and wanting more and more and more until
it comes out right oh yeah well because
you know movie trailers come out every
few
weeks or months you know game trailers
come out every
several months or a couple of years so
it's an event i'm curious to know more
of what will make it special and i can't
wait to see what the gameplay would
ultimately be like but right now this
tease at what the world is and who our
main characters could potentially be
does sound pretty intriguing to me
and uh the tone of it i really liked a
lot too the dystopian something about
like a large
satellite crashing through screen sky
falling to earth it plays on
so many irrational fears yeah of mine so
seeing like that
play out in this just was really
gripping again it reminded me of other
things and even in just the design
qualities there are certain elements
that reminded me of other games intrigue
mystery alone is what's hooking me here
yeah basically and going out to the moon
you know i wasn't quite expecting
something as grounded as like oh it's
earth and the moon
yeah especially after coming off like
the horizon trailer where it's like as a
whole
other version of the world you know and
this looks like it's slightly into the
future but not
so much that it's unrecognizably a
different place you wonder what he meant
by freedom people living on the moon now
or maybe they're free from everything on
earth yeah
this is the two of them
what does pragmata
mean in proculus pragmata also means
transcendent reality is nowettic
entities and real beings
in greek it means advice done been
done or
[Laughter]
this google's search is very it's not
nailing it down
all right supposed to be a mystery and
right now the mystery's got me intrigued
it means this guy's pragmatic he's not
gonna make any weird crazy decisions all
right
he's gonna be grounded all right guys
well what do you think about that
trailer let's check out the resident
evil one now
john much more familiar with the
resident evil games than me i love the
resident evil series as a matter of fact
and i'm not being sarcastic either
long ago a young girl went with her
mother to be fairies for her father
it was hard at work
but the forest greeted them with a dark
cold silence
the bushes empty
yet determined to find the berries the
rascal broke free of mother's grass
and vanished into the trees mothers
worried cries faded fast as the girl ran
on
over vine under branch
and into the forest
what is it with that creepy story it's
just a local tale
you're really into that stuff
quit being so paranoid
oh
sounds like a han zimmer tune yeah
oh
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
yay
that's clever
thank god they did that for me
huh sorry ethan
whoa whoa whoa whoa
why oh
something's up with chris he's changed
yeah his designs changed
he looks very different in seven but he
looks closer to how he was in six
yeah which is the one that's really not
a scary game
that's uh it's just like a freaking
shoot em up one six
yeah that one was the one that people
didn't love so much
no because it's not i mean it seems like
they've really prioritized this vision
no that's all it really was survival
horror stuff
this looks very grounded might be the
last comparison you guys expected from
me i've kind of brought the show up a
lot
there's a show called hannibal nbc which
is now on netflix and if you guys are
familiar with the show at all
especially in its more colder settings
and the more fantastical ethereal tones
it does
look like that hannibal's show a lot if
you've seen the show you probably know
exactly what i'm getting at with here
this is obviously a continuation you got
chris redfield back here
and you're continuing as ethan i think i
mean yeah he's saying sorry ethan he
must be ethan considering over here yeah
but you know not not a completely new
ensemble you know
if they didn't show just a couple of
moments it could have been confusing
as to is this like an older period piece
type of tale and it looks like they're
going to be doing some things in this
game where you're going to be
i don't know if it's going to be like
more spiritual sense
or if you will there's an actual flash
natural stuff i know there's a
hallucination element built into this as
well and there's some dubiousness as to
whether or not
uh the the woman the wife character
who's reading the creepy poem
what her status is because to my
understanding the way our resident evil
7 finishes that character can
or maybe not survive you know with
multiple outcomes i am very curious as
to what the continuity will be but yeah
i mean this
especially as compared to six and and
even
what they were starting to go for with
five and everything and in
engaging with the elements this really
does remind me of the older stuff in the
sense that
it is very breathy it's very airy you
know it's not like just piles and piles
of zombies so you do feel that just
creeping dread even just going through
the snow i love that and they've changed
the perspective i know that in these
ones
some people have been anticipating maybe
return to third person
at least based off the last game being
in first person which i guess they're
going to continue with the first person
here but
that i think adds a certain level of
freakiness especially when you're
playing in vr
i mean i really appreciate it because
like the last game they took it back to
a you know like
old style plantation farmhouse thing
which you know the first resident evil
you're in like an old mansion with
surrounding woods and i think that makes
a lot of sense the more abandoned areas
that you're in
here it makes me curious because they've
always had the bio-organic weapons and
stuff like that and the mutated people
but yeah what you pointed out is
is it looks like we're almost seeing
heavier influx of like
supernatural witchcrafty
almost like weird eyes wide shut stuff i
mean yeah it kind of looks like there's
cultish elements yeah
mixed into it it's resident evil village
historical roots look like they're gonna
play a big
factor into this because if they're
calling it the village like what is the
village this is gonna be taking place in
what's the story with this town and also
like i mean
leaving this off with the big tease
who's chris redfield becoming
you know he seems like he's morphing
into a person that he always fought
against
and now he's becoming this at least what
the trailer is making it look like you
know yeah man well when you've been a
part of this franchise as long as he has
been involved with every iteration of
the umbrella corp as he has
you know especially if you're gonna use
characters so many times over time i
guess that would make a lot of sense for
him to
have an arc finally you know that's not
just about surviving whatever situation
and
maybe rescuing his sister but yeah
there's one of the biggest stretches to
come out in the last couple days and i
know people are very much excited for it
so
what do you guys think of the trailer
are you part of the fan base that's
excited for it leave your thoughts down
below
i want to play the remake of whether
they just released three right i want to
play that really
okay two and three i've heard that one's
so good but i heard part two sucks
yeah that's right that's exactly the
right order that comes in yeah i believe
that's what the word of mouth is that's
right
and then these games should really just
lean into the action and really out of
the zombie survival horse
people really don't want it scary just
want to shoot them up right all right
guys well
thanks for being here subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell last but not least
michael b if you guys are not following
omni media on youtube you have no idea
what you're doing i once did an
experiment with my friend here we
sometimes message each other back and
forth on patreon
might take like a week or two to get
back to one another one time i was like
you know what he sends me long messages
i'm gonna do a little fun experiment i
counted what was it it's like
1700 characters it's like that's a lot
1700 words yeah that's a lot of words
right there
but there's a reason i engage with the
guy he is very intelligent
very informative he really knows his
stuff makes sense why his channel is
growing
so if you guys are into gaming comics
anything pretty much
fandom or geekdom related this guy
really knows this [ __ ] so go
check him out omni media as soon as you
can i'm looking forward to your next
message thread which i believe has 3 600
words in it
only taking about an hour to get back to
you but it's gonna be worth my time
buddy
dude some days are gonna get published
and it's all gonna be worth it i mean
some people are
like dude why haven't you gotten this
video up and i'm like
i'm replying to michael b he's taking
the time to really soak the messages in
formulate my own 6 000 word response
don't worry michael i know i do the same
thing to you
it's not like you do it and i'm very
short
i cool yeah i tend to give back these
same amounts so
that's why it stays that way